they have reached their final stage this
is literally of this era that they're in
right now
this is their final stage in saying
race racism race is the problem race
black people race race race systematic
racism that's why you're not successful
elect us we will help you so this is
kind of the final stage of this
and if it wasn't then there wouldn't be
so many voices like like mine
like like our friend candace owens like
so many other black voices iona presley
though
our voices are still black voices and
there's so many of those voices that are
saying
wait a minute this stuff isn't
necessarily true
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report do yourself a favor everyone and
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that notification bell so you
might just see our videos
and joining me today is an iraq veteran
host
of rob smith is problematic and the
author of the new book
always a soldier service sacrifice and
coming out
as america's favorite black gay
republican
rob smith welcome to the reuben report
thanks for having me dave
wordy title rob wordy title
it's a wordy title but i think the main
thing is always a soldier
and the sub the subheading is america's
favorite black gay republican i have to
put that
in there peaks people's all right well
we're gonna talk about that black gay
republican thing
obviously and we've talked about it
before and you've been on the show and
we're buddies
uh but if i'm not mistaken you've been
doing uh lockdown
in brooklyn that's like ground zero of
this this crazy thing how's it going
uh terrible uh actually new york is
you know it it is it is very very bad
it's bad for
your physical health is bad for your
mental health it's a very very
weird situation that's going on in new
york city right now and and look there
are
some signs that that people are
returning to normalcy we've got
dining on the streets which is nice but
when you walk around
and everybody's wearing the mask it's
like you're in a zombie movie
and you see people driving around solo
wearing the mask and you see people
walking around
in the fresh and open air in the mask it
just it's weird
and it sort of engenders this sense of
hysteria
that is not particularly worn
yeah does it strike you as depending
whether you're wired to just sort of
listen to authority and no matter what
they say you're going to do it
or if you're someone with a little more
of a rebellious streak you're going to
be
a little more questioning of it is that
really just the divide we have in
society right now when it comes to this
that's the divide because here's the
thing now the the mass
issue has become so politicized so now
there's the good people and the bad
people right
so if you're good you're wearing a mask
all the time you're you're
always social distancing no matter what
i i had dinner with uh with a buddy of
mine
uh and his husband his husband was is
good you know
he's good and he was just like we can't
share and we have
social distance we have to do that um so
it is and
the thing that strikes me the most is
there are people out there not to get
too heavily into politics but the people
out here that that utterly
um hate the government hate the
administration hate all of this stuff
and yet yes they will follow these rules
to to the t and it's just it's really
it's just strange to me
it's bizarre did you just say you don't
want to get too deep into politics do
you know what show you're doing
oh i know a show i'm doing but i think
when i say i want to get too deep like i
don't want to sit here and talk about
the president or for the next 45 minutes
but just even deeper than that
um yeah the rebels that are out here
that are saying okay look you know
we know the science of this i probably
don't need to wear a mask
when i'm in my car driving by myself and
and that's the divide that we have on
right it's it's strange
do you sense that people in new york uh
are gonna have some point where they
snap where they go
oh maybe cuomo wasn't as great as the
media portrayed him to be at the
beginning and he sent all those people
back into the uh the old age homes
and the fact that these rolling lockouts
continue and
lockdowns continue and everything else i
mean i think that people are asking the
conversation but
what you have to understand about cuomo
is that there is such an
infrastructure protecting them right now
when you talk about the mainstream media
where is most of it is based most of
it's based in new york right
so this is why we have this narrative
right now that's going on where it's
saying
oh well now florida is the epicenter of
pronovirus and the numbers in no
way shape or form when it comes to
hospitalizations when it comes to
any of any of those metrics that they
introduced
you know in those 15 days to slow the
spread that ended up being
whatever day we're on right now so
florida is not hitting any of those
metrics at all but yet
the narrative has changed to make
florida the epicenter to make florida
the bad guy to make ron desantis the bad
guy because of course he's a republican
um and cuomo is going to be their kind
of great
hope uh they think for 2024 because i i
believe that that
they know that biden has problems and
they know that he's not likely to win
so they're protecting cuomo right now
it's really unfortunate but
i think that more people see through the
nonsense
now um than before so you know that
gives me a little bit of hope
yeah as of our taping this because we
are holding this for a little bit it's
something like 10 times the death
in new york than there are in florida
it's it's something around there
which you would think maybe the media
would pick up on but uh only those
far-right websites
are are big on that yeah i know are
right i know we could talk about corona
the whole time but i have some notes
here and according to my paper here uh
you are black is that
is that correct that that that is
correct
i am black okay i vaguely remembered
that
i vaguely remembered that from the last
time we were together um
let's talk about race because nobody
else is talking about race let's talk
about races
there's uh there's a lot of weird stuff
going on about race
suddenly america is the most evil racist
nation
in the history of the world you've got
peop you know the the whole
i would say democratic machine is
running on the idea that trump has
has just proliferated racism but also
the system was deeply racist before him
which is quite a condemnation of
uh biden and schumer and pelosi and
everybody else that's been around
forever
what do you feel is the temperature
right now just in
in a broad sense i mean i i feel like
honestly the temperature when
there there are two different worlds
here right there are so there's our
social media world
um in the social media world on twitter
and facebook and instagram and
everywhere else is constantly at each
other throats there's all this division
there's all this
because the powers that be particularly
on the left right now they they want
that division they think that
um ginning up that stuff is going to
push them back
into power but there's also the real
world as well
and and i think and maybe this is just
my
unabashed uh optimism for america but i
think that
there's a conversation that is happening
in the real world that is nowhere near
as is elevated and heightened as the
conversation of social media but
look i i think that what you have going
on right now is
the democrats in the left they have
reached their final stage
this is literally of this era that
they're in right now
this is their final stage in saying
race racism race is the problem race
black people race race race systematic
racism that's why you're not successful
elect us we will help you so this is
kind of the final stage of this
and if it wasn't then there wouldn't be
so many voices like like mine like like
our friend candace owens like
so many other black voices iona presley
though
our voices are still black voices and
there's so many of those voices that are
saying
wait a minute this stuff isn't
necessarily true
and that gives me hope that there can be
a more elevated conversation but let me
tell you
i hope and i truly do pray
that they lose in november not because i
am praying so much for the republicans
and
and the president is going to save our
republic although there's a big part of
that
but they have to realize that this is
not the way
for power this is not the way for votes
and i think that they have to get
shellacked a couple of times
to really figure it out and there's
going to be a lot of collateral damage
in the form of the the minds of some of
the young african-americans that they
are literally
destroying by selling this message that
racism is the number one problem in
their life
in order to get vote for democrats it's
destructive
it's insidious and i think that people
are starting to wake up to it
i like the way you describe that because
it does feel like we're sort of getting
if this is a video game we're getting to
the big boss we're getting to the final
boss where for
for eight levels they've just ramped up
the racism racism homophobia blah blah
blah and now we're there like this
election is it and and it almost seems
to me
that all they've got to run on is that
america is racist and if they don't have
that
it's like i don't think anyone buys any
of the policies and
unfortunately just the way the media
operates right now this isn't going to
be an election about policy this is an
election about basically
racism and socialism versus capitalism
and
and freedom something like that yeah you
know it is and and dave the thing that
always strikes me because i i watch some
of the left-leaning stuff and and god i
see this
you know never-ending clown car of of
the black liberals that come up and then
they talk about stuff so case in point
um so the mccloskey situation where
where this couple was defending
themselves from from
an angry mob who had by the way broken
into private property
and on the left with with the black
pundits this somehow becomes about
race and this somehow becomes the idea
of these people
um inflicting their white supremacy on
these black protesters um number one
those those protesters are not peaceful
number two they were not all black
and number three the last time i checked
the second amendment in the right to
bear arms is for everybody
it's not just for for white people so
i'm struck when i see these
conversations how
how quickly and how easily they remove
all agency from black people in america
and from african americans
in general they all of our agency is
removed in these conversations
yeah well it's also incredible because
they try to paint the mccloskeys as evil
for defending their property as we
as we're watching all this stuff burned
down but it's not like the mccloskeys
woke up that morning and we're like
we're gonna go shoot people they
they had those guns for a long time it
sounds like they were actually
democratic donors at least at one point
and
supported black lives matter it's not
like they were just sitting there
waiting
to start some stuff it literally showed
up at their door
and then they defended themselves but
that's actually a good transition to
to media because you're uh you're a
media what can i call you assassin
i suppose as well you've just had it
with the with the mainstream media too
because this is the stuff they're
endlessly pedaling right
well it is and and a lot of people don't
realize dave that um so i went to
columbia journalism school i got my
master's group columbia
i worked in in medium production for
years before i decided to come out and
and say what i really thought and do all
this for myself so i know
all the games dude i know about trapping
a tweet
and leaving half of the code off um i
know what fake news is because sometimes
fake news are actually most of the time
fake news isn't an outright lie but more
a half
truth and and so you see past all these
games when i first came out as
conservative i
one of the first friends that i lost um
got deeply offended when i told him and
not in a condescending way at all
told him that i've been working in this
at that point for about five to six
years and i know these games
and you're not media literate enough to
see this and he got deeply offended by
it and then that was it and
just like it's whatever um but people
didn't realize these games and i think
the deeper we get into this we see it
over and over and over again and folks
like like you and i
when there is an outright lie and i mean
a
whopper it has to be shut down so quick
because if you don't then it becomes
part of the lexicon and it becomes
common knowledge
case in point of trump very fine
people comment which has been debunked
so
many times but it is canon
among the left and that's because and
that was a feeling on the right because
they didn't shut that down
immediately immediately when they shut
up
you know what's interesting about that
one is that uh for people that don't
know
a minute not even a minute 30 seconds
before trump said very fine people
on both sides he absolutely condemned
the neo-nazis and the white supremacists
but what's really amazing about it is
that biden when he launched his campaign
that's the video he used the very fine
people and he's talking about america
being racist and everything else and he
knows he can get away with it
because nobody in the media is going to
do anything about it and then yeah
us on twitter we'll hit back but he
knows uh cnn and msnbc and everybody
else going to run cover for him
of course they knew it and and honestly
he knew it when he played the video
they they look at a certain point and i
think that media bashing
is definitely it's a fun pastime that
that a lot of us like to do on the right
um but at a certain point you can fool
some of the people some of the time but
you cannot fool
all the people all the time and what is
going to happen on the left is is people
are going to start asking questions
they're going to start asking bad
questions they're going to start asking
questions that they shouldn't have asked
before
and then they will be excommunicated
just like you were
just as i was and and so i think and and
you
have been way at the forefront of this
because you saw
all of this stuff coming for a long time
before the rest of us
and so then the same thinking people are
going to have to figure out
what do we create that is new that is
fact based
and you can beat look some of my best
friends are liberals you can be a
liberal and not be
an insane left right just like you can
be a conservative and and not be
super crazy far right but at a certain
point
the grown-ups are gonna have to take
control of the conversation here and and
that's what i'm trying to do and i know
that's what you have been doing
yeah so all right let's let's make this
about us for a second
so if you take two guys like if you take
two guys like us you take dave rubin you
take rob smith
and you go wait a minute these guys sort
of seem like what would be i think you
could call sort of new
conservatives something like that we
don't look like you know we're both
married to dudes that's a little
different than
uh you know traditional conservatism um
what do you think what do you think our
kind of
new role or the younger newer
conservative role
is within the conservative movement
okay so this is what i think and i've
been i think about this a lot and it's
like
everything that i'm doing from from here
on out with with
everything that we'll be talking about a
little bit is about this so it's like
how do we usher in the conservative
movement in the conservative movement
into this new era where
you got more black people you got more
more people of color you got more gays
you got whatever
and i think that what we do is
we define a love for country and a love
for america that is
not completely uncritical but
it is not based in some sort of idea
that it was created to permanently and
perpetually
keep people like us in some way
oppressed because i think that
the um and i was speaking with uh with
uh lara trump
earlier about this thing so this is
about creating a more perfect union
so this is not about pretending that
america was always
perfect this is about this is about
perfecting this union
and we have to open up this idea of the
american experiment to everybody because
what the left says right now to people
like you and people like me and
and a lot of different people is that
america
was never for you america is not for you
you cannot survive here you cannot exist
here
this uh system is racist and the only
way that you will ever be free or be
successful
is if you join with us and tearing this
all down via via socialism leptism
whatever you want to call it
and so our job is to reach out to to not
only to people like us but also
these mainstream conservatives that look
like your typical conservative they
those people make up a lot of the people
that follow both of us
and so and to kind of bring everybody
into this idea
of of what is america and how do we love
america
from all vantage points yeah i think the
hard part for some people when when they
see what you know people like
we are doing people like us i think the
hard part is they go well wait a minute
there's still such a strong religious
bent
uh yeah to the right that this just
doesn't make sense
they think you guys are sinners
something like that and people go well
reuben how can you be friends with
shapiro and it's like yes he has a
different
view of biblical marriage but he's not
trying to legislate my life
it does put a cap on our friendship
right i can be friends with you in a way
that i can't be with him because of that
thing but it's
but it doesn't but i know he's way more
tolerant than all the other people that
are screaming about tolerance all the
time
but what would you say to if a young a
young gay person
that is trying to become part of this or
or understand this
what would you say to them about that i
would say to them that that first of all
just like you articulated it
pretty well um is that a difference of
opinion
and actively legislating against things
there are two different things right
and you know it gets into the religious
freedom conversation which is a whole
other conversation as well
but this is what i say to the the
younger gay person that
is reaching out to me that may be
leaning conservative and that has
problems with the religious thing first
of all
i tell them number one you know you're
jewish i'm christian
i i think that the left in the far left
uses um they use this this idea
that most uh evangelical christians are
super far right hate gay people all of
that stuff
to separate them from the gift that is
having a connection to
whatever your belief is for me it's that
belief in christianity and the belief in
god
and they would want to separate these
guys
these young um gays and lesbians from
that
so that they can worship at the altar of
leptism
so they can worship at the author alter
politics so that they they can worship
at the altar of as i always call it the
lgbtq cult
so they want these kids worshiping at
that altar
and not uh at the altar of of their
creator whoever they believe that they
may be
if that makes any sense at all and i'll
tell you furthermore
that i have made inroads
with a lot of these conservative
christians and they'll say look
i still believe like you and and and bin
shapiro even though uh
you and bishop parable jewish i'll have
these conversations with these
conservative christians and they'll say
i my belief is that marriage is between
a man and a woman that is what i believe
but you go ahead and live your best
life and if neither of us are hurting
each other we can coexist
and that is tolerant
that is tolerance that that is america
uh you know it's like i
i spoke at liberty university the
largest evangelical college in the
united states in front of 14
000 kids it was like a true political
rally the biggest crowd i've ever spoken
front of
and they freaking loved me and i went
around campus all day long shaking hands
and hugging people and
and it was great and it's like those are
the intolerant people i think we're
doing something backwards over here
yeah maybe um and it seems like nowadays
like look the
the most intolerant people are on the
left these are the people that are the
most intolerant these are the people
that are
the most likely to throw out slurs you
know you're homophobe racist
nazi all of this other stuff the people
who
even slightly um disagree with any of
their stuff or even
gen gently call out leftist policies
this is what they do it these are shut
down terms i hope
that they start to mean less um as we
move into this this uh
new world we're trying to get into yeah
so i know you hate
sort of the phrase community whether we
say the black community or the lgbt
community because we are all individuals
ultimately
but sometimes sometimes we just need
some of these words to to explain
situations but do you sense a really
weird
tension in the black community related
to
identity because of color and then the
sexuality thing because
it seems to me and we keep seeing videos
of this pop up online
where there'll be black people that are
suddenly they're stuck in this
intersectional thing and they're
suddenly going no i have traditional
you know beliefs and i'm not down with
all that lgbt
stuff and and these things have been
sort of morphed into a very weird thing
where suddenly
if you if you're you have to be suddenly
black trans lives matter i'm personally
fine with black trans people of course
but suddenly they create this thing
where it's just like you have to be for
all of these things
no matter what your other set of beliefs
are
so that is is the rub right now with
black lives matter because
when you go to the black lives matter
the organization's website
right and then i'm not talking about you
know the don lemons running cover for
them in the media i'm not talking about
when you go to the organization's
website
they say things like they're in favor of
abolishing the nuclear family
um centering lgbtqia
plus queer people all of this stuff all
of this
stuff that the vast majority of
regular working-class black americans
are not super
into or even down with so there is a lot
of that tension there
um in this is the problem with
when you let brands organizations and
corporations define
black because black lives matter does
not define black
my blackness is not defined by black
lives matter any of their founders or
any of the people that
have you know put themselves in the
position to speak for this
organization like i said there's an
organization as a corporation
um this is a business and they don't
speak for me so there
is a lot of tension there and
furthermore so i talk a lot about i say
lgbtq cult a lot right
um so there are gays and they're
lesbians and they're bisexuals and
they're transgender people most of which
are
law-abiding tax-paying citizens that
just want to live their lives and
pretty much be left alone then there is
the lgbtq
cult and the cultists say
that you will listen to whatever we say
whatever we change
is the idea so if we want to use
pronouns this is what you call us or
else we will find you
um if you do not agree with adding
transgender women to
the spaces for actual women you are now
transphobic and it is all of that stuff
that is going
crazy and and it's stopping and i break
this down there's a whole chapter in
this book called escaping the lgbtq
cult where i kind of break all that
stuff down
and that is the stuff that most people
are not down with
most people don't care about gays and
lesbians we're past that point now
but they see all the cult stuff and they
think that that represents all of us
and it just doesn't yeah so let's talk
about the cult stuff a little bit
because we we've talked about this
privately a bunch um that the t part of
this the transgender part
you and i as gay people we have no more
insight into what it is to be a trans
person
than a straight person does we were born
in the right body
we have same sex attraction but that's
not being born you know born in the
the wrong body that you identify with
let's say um
yet the tea thing has sort of now taken
over the entire
movement and you were telling me uh last
time i saw you that that you think it's
actually
rabidly anti-gay and i think it's it's a
pretty interesting theory
yeah um so look the uh the transgender
movement as we know it today especially
the very hard left transit to move in is
one of the most homophobic movements
i've ever seen in my life
because it is this idea that if you are
a gay man or even a gay boy because now
you know a feminine little boy is now
being pushed towards
transition and puberty blockers and all
of this other stuff uh by by the
the radical leftist transgender movement
so it's this idea that if you are in
some way not conforming
to typical standards of gender
then you must be the other gender right
be literally other sex so if you're a
little femme gay boy
then no you're really a woman if you're
a masculine
sort of like butchy you know a lesbian
then no you're really a man and from
what i've learned about some of the the
right you'll call them they call them
radical feminists that are really
fighting
against that ideology is that this
transgender movement
and and the radical elements of it are
affecting
teenage girls the most and so you have a
high preponderance of of
teenage girls who basically are just
going to end up being lesbians right
because you realize that most uh most
gay and lesbian queens teenagers who are
gender non-conforming in some way
upwards of 80 percent of them just end
up being regular gays and lesbian
but the idea is to stop all of this
in its tracks before puberty is actually
done so that we create can create
more transgender people in this there
are going to be some people that are
watching it that think that i am
absolutely crazy right but this is
happening before our very eyes
and the mainstream media is so afraid
to stand up against that lobby they do
not report that um i worked very hard on
that chapter in my book that deals with
this
and and there are documented stories
about
um god when you want to talk about
women who were born men in women's
prisons um sexually assaulting female in
inmates document um and and you have
somebody like joe biden that is
literally running
on um your gender is what you say it is
and if that's so then they should be put
in women's presence and and
this is something that joe biden has
literally said
it's in the book it's a real thing and
it's another way
the media is running cover for them
right yeah
just to keep going with that for a
second the twisted part of it is that
they
in many ways are the ones who are
conforming more so
to traditional ideas of gender because
they're the ones that are going
oh if you're a boy but you act a little
more feminine so you're five years old
and instead of playing with
g.i joes as i did you play with barbie
well then we must transition you to a
girl so
oddly it's their view of gender that
in many ways is more traditional than
someone just saying okay he's a boy he
plays with barbie
and he'll grow up to love whoever he
loves it's true and you know what the
the more insidious thing about the the
far left trans movement that's going on
right now
is that they have they are starting to
align themselves with the
more hardcore homophobic elements of the
religious
right um so we're talking far right the
people that haven't really gotten over
their homophobe because in some of these
people's minds
they would rather have a transgender
daughter than a gay son
right they would rather have um a trans
son
than just a daughter that is lesbian and
you see a lot of that stuff happening
right now so there's this very
weird sort of alignment that's happening
on the fringes on the very far left and
the very far
right it's it's homophobic um it has
obviously no basin basis in real science
and
look i i take a lot of stuff when i
really dig deep into this but i
fought okay for the rights of gays and
lesbians
for my entire career and i just want
these young gay and lesbian teenagers to
be
comfortable with who they are because
they are being set down a path that is
going to lead
down to nothing but permanent
unhappiness
um in the physical destruction of their
body
in this idea that somehow
transitioning is going to make them
happy
and look the the post-transition suicide
rates
do not bear that out there they're very
very high so
if this was really truly making people
happy
then why did the suicide rates go up
post-transition instead of down
did you watch the show transparent by
any chance
um i didn't it was just a little too i
don't know
just like i wasn't into it it became
pretty sjw
you know heavy but there was an
interesting moment where you know the
the
story is about the father of this family
um transitioning
and there's a moment where another trans
person
says to him something to the effect of
this is gonna destroy your whole family
and your life and he basically was like
well i'm gonna go go ahead and do it
anyway
i thought that was an interest sort of
honest interesting
moment of this but that that we just
celebrate all this stuff without
thinking what some of the consequences
are and again that's not to be against
someone who genuinely is trans doing
what they think is right for them
yeah and i mean it is and it's so funny
that moment that sounds like a
compelling moment it had to have come
during the first season before
because yeah it was it was i think it
was the last episode last episode of the
first season if i'm not mistaken
it had to have been because they were
probably creating this show in
like a creative bubble where they were
allowing themselves to have those
conversations
and then once something comes out and
then the far left owns it
and then they dictate what is safe to
say or not to say
they dictate what conversations are
available to have and remember speaking
of transparent they got that guy jeffy
jeffrey tambour the the actor right the
lead actor they got him jumped off the
show for for whatever reason
so look these people destroy whatever
they touch
first of all um and and second of all
that sounds compelling
and it's unfortunate that they went over
into sjw territory but when the cult
gets their clutches in you
there's nowhere else to go yeah
let's uh let's shift to something we've
talked about a little bit before but i
let's preempt the haters rob they're
going to say wait a minute how could the
subtitle of this book
be america's favorite gay black
republican he's using their language
he's using identity politics rob oh no
what's going on here rob
you know that that is such a common uh
misconception in
um fatigue oh oh you say that you're so
against identity politics and yet you're
america's favorite black
republican okay so first of all i use
identity politics in this way because
yes everybody uses identity politics
right
so i use identity politics in this way
so that i can tell
other gay people other black people and
some people that like me or both
that they don't have to be on the left
they don't have to be democrat they
don't have to be liberals they don't
have to be leftists
just because of their immutable
characteristic
that happened at birth that they have
zero control of right
and so that is the idea because if you
can get that
broken down in people's minds then we
can actually start talking about ideas
and we can start talking about what are
the best solutions on the path toward
american prosperity or american success
or the american evolution whatever you
want to talk about but the more the more
the left is able to engage people that
that look like me
that have my same sexual orientation
whatever the more
that the left and leftism is able to
rein them
in their clutches based purely on these
immutable characteristics
i think the weaker that we become as
americans and the further we get
from that identity as americans that
that i'm trying to push us
so that is why i use identity politics
in this way
that is why i call myself america's
favorite black gay republican
for anybody that has any problems with
that you don't have to support me you
don't have to buy the book
you don't have to do anything at all
look at you you're not going to force
people to support you you truly are a
liberty lover
truly truly so so remember all the way
back when to like february when
we were pre-pandemic and we were having
those democratic debates do you remember
that time of life
oh my god it seems like a million years
ago at this point
so there was one of the debates when the
democrats were all
going on and on bernie and elizabeth and
the whole crew
about how racist america was and and i
tweeted out
something to the effect of i said you
know i think it sounds crazy but trump's
going to get 30
of the black vote and they know it and
that's why they're freaking out because
before the pandemic
we know that black unemployment was at
an all-time low there was that crazy
moment
at the state of the union where he he
actually trump actually says that
and you watch the members of the
congressional black caucus
sit there like this as if as if this is
a problem i thought that's why they have
their caucus because we want people to
be prosperous and all that um
then we have now these months of of
race stuff um
what what do you think is gonna happen
which way do you think
the the black vote is is gonna break at
the end of all this
well look i i think that pre pandemic
honestly things were going so well for
for everybody
um if you would ask me that question
pre-plan pandemic
i would have said oh yeah you know 30 40
whatever
you know that that was probably a little
high even before pretty pandemic
but i think that what you're saying
right now this this this race war
that that the left is is fully behind it
and really wants to happen and all of
this idea brace and all this stuff
you have to understand that these people
are freaking
out they are terrified
that black americans are really starting
to see past their game when you look at
a millennial like me
um i have lived through a little bit of
this and and i used to be on the left
and i've
made no bones about that but it just
gets to the point where
you've seen this all before so you've
seen this story play out over and over
and over again
so you get to the point where you're
like me and you're post 30 and you're
just looking at this stuff
and then you start saying wait a minute
and you start thinking differently
and then you you amass a platform where
people actually start listening to your
thoughts and there are people like me
and and god there's so many people out
there there's the me and the candace and
brandon tatum and there's more than i
can count right now
which is great which is a good thing and
that
freaks the left out because they can
only control
the the black people that they've
ushered into positions of power
in in their sort of media uh control
groups right so
the cnns and the msnbc's of the world
but there's a lot of conversation that
is happening with us and i will tell you
um dave my social media when all of
these
rights and all this stuff started
happening exploded
and when i tell you the following in all
platforms just completely exploded
and it tells me that people are hungry
for a different perspective
so back to the black vote i think we're
looking at somewhere between
and to be completely honest and 100 real
i think we're looking at somewhere
between 12 and 15
and even if we get to 12 that's a
33 jump from from 2016
and if you get to 15 and 16 that is
double all right what he did in in 2016
and democrats cannot win national
elections without
upwards of 90 of the african-american
vote they know this this is why they did
not win
in um 2016 because black people just
stayed home because they didn't want to
vote for hillary because
of a lot of different reasons and yet
they do the same thing they they trot
out another deeply unpopular
super establishment candidate that's
been around for
forever and say that this is gonna be
our change candidate so they make these
same mistakes over and over and over
again
the guy who's going to change all of the
systemic racism is the guy that was in
the senate for like 30 years and was
vice president for eight years this time
he's going to do it right it's
incredible yeah this time he's going to
do the right and it's the same guy that
didn't want um
integration in schools because he said
that it would turn schools into a quote
racial jungle
yes joe biden said that look it up
yeah what a what a weird thing do you do
you sense the gays are going to have a
similar crack
the gays oh the gays god dave the gays
the gays
um i i try my best with the gays i
honestly
really don't know i you can only okay so
you can only judge by
the following that you get and you can
judge by the dms and
and the emails and stuff that i get but
also i i'm in
in florida right now the games are
generally generally more conservative
leaning
i think that there is a subset and there
always has been
of gays and lesbians that are working
and law abiding citizens and they look
at some of this stuff and it
it just doesn't jive with you know uh
and i hope and i pray that the gays wake
up i think that a lot of them
privately are not into the cult stuff i
think that a lot of them privately
either don't vote for for liberals or or
possibly even vote for republicans
possibly even vote for trump
but they would never dare say it
because they would never want to be
excommunicated like i said
which is what happened to you and i so
yeah i think we talked about this
last time but i honestly can't remember
the the closet thing you know coming out
as a gay person versus coming out as
conservative or on the right or or
basically anything non-woke
at this point um which was harder for
you
it was so when you come out as gay
nowadays
right you know you everybody loves it
and it's so accepting and
it's all good and it's whatever coming
out as conservative
it was one of the most disruptive life
events i've ever had in my life
and you're talking about somebody you're
talking to somebody that's been to war
right
so coming out literally yeah literally
literally been to war
so coming in as conservative was such a
disruptive life event and i talked about
this a little bit
um losing all your friends
um having some family members say what
what are you doing people that were
at my wedding no longer talk to me
all right um the best man at my wedding
no longer talks to me so it's just
it's a very disruptive event so if i had
to say which one was harder for me it
was coming out as conservative
because you're coming out as gay people
are just like oh okay well you know
sometimes there's a problem with that
um most times there's not in 2020 but
when you come out
as a conservative this this stigma that
is thrown on your shoulders
is that you are based you are basically
hitler
you are basically supporting the worst
most
racist xenophobic homophobic
the worst of humanity as i was called
on social media um and so that is very
disruptive
and you have to have a very strong sense
of self
to come out of it on the other side
that's why i so openly share my story
that people get fired from their jobs
people i it was the most heartbreaking
thing um
one of my followers on facebook reached
out to me
and her two grown adult children
called her a racist nazi and completely
cut her out of their life
and those stories make me so sad
yeah i mean i i get many of those
messages and and the best you can do
is try to slowly bring people back
because or or you can live on your knees
forever and in many ways that's what
they want you to do
i just don't think it's a good way for
people to live but those are your only
choices
yeah i mean according to what that said
either you agree with me
in every single way in every single
capacity on every single thing that we
say
on all issues or you're one of them
and you're you're excommunicated you're
kicked out and i say this all the time
when when some leftist comes from me on
twitter and i decided to engage
i say watch out all right because one
day
you're gonna you're gonna have a
problematic thought right
you're gonna think something different
you're gonna think something that is
outside of this orthodoxy that you've
been boxed into
and they'll come for you too that that
really is it
that in many ways is the one thing
that'll wake everybody up you're gonna
have
some flicker of individual thought and
no matter how religiously progressive
you are
if you dare say it it's gonna turn on
you and then you're gonna go whoops
maybe i shouldn't have called all those
people
self-hating black people self-hating gay
people and the rest of it you just said
the word problematic you've got a
podcast coming out
another podcast there's another podcast
coming out rob smith
he's problematic what are you going to
be doing on the rob smith
is pop problematic podcast oh first of
all i'm going to be being problematic so
problematic if some of your viewers
aren't
um if you're not so up to the
terminology problematic is what a lot of
people on the left
like to call people who step outside of
of these
boxes of liberal orthodoxy so you know
i'm
deeply problematic look i'm a black gay
republican i'm about as problematic as
you get right
and so what i want to do is i want to
number one take that word back
i want to have problematic conversations
about what is going on in the world and
i've
got this community we call them the
problematics because a lot of people
that that follow both you and
i are problematic in some way shape or
form so it's time for us to own that
have real conversations and by the way
this is not particularly a conservative
thing
because i'm very problematic to a lot of
people on the right as well because i am
gay
and so i wanted to create this space
to have these conversations um to also
define what being problematic
is make people proud of being
problematic
and also dig a little bit deeper into
these things that that really sort of
interest me and a lot of us
talking about the lgbtq cult talking
about school choice for black kids
talking about the black vote
and i think that there's a way to have
this conversation
that is not angry what we're not going
to be doing on the podcast is i'm not
going to be
railing again i'm not going to be
talking about what political bs happened
this week
between who said what in the halls of
congress of this bill because people
don't care
they care about their lives and they
care about the big ideas
and i want to give people something they
can use i want to give them a uh
in the in the leftist terminology a safe
space
oh lord oh lord safe space problematic
are you gonna put a trigger warning
i should you should put a trigger
warning you know speaking of problematic
uh last time you and your husband were
at our house
uh you brought over several bottles of
champagne we were going with wine and
then suddenly tequila shots got involved
i i haven't had a hangover in about i
don't know probably eight years
i was extremely hungover i hope you're
happy about that
um you know i did not give you that
tequila
and as a matter of fact if you remember
correctly did i do tequila oh no i did
because i was i was super hungover the
next day too um yes because i had golden
girl shot glasses
that's what it was god you're always
bribing me with the golden girl shot
glasses
and we went to palm springs the next
morning i was so hungover that entire
day it was it was awful
so like red wine to champagne to tequila
bad move you should know that's a rookie
mistake dave you should know better
well that's what i'm saying the whole
thing was problematic that that's the
point
yeah that's the point problematic
where can people find the book rob
promote yourself
yes promote myself so you can find this
book always a soldier service sacrifice
and coming out
as america's favorite black gay
republican wherever books are sold
but seeing as how i am so problematic
you can have an easier time finding it
on amazon
for as long as amazon will let it be
there all right
and if you guys know someone who could
appreciate a different viewpoint be sure
to share this video by clicking
the share arrow below if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell